le faire nous verrions de la coved qui a
complètement débordé le système de santé
indien et qui seraient pas maintenant
dans le monde répondent bien aux vaccins
indique une nouvelle étude dont les
résultats sont préliminaires selon
l'étude après deux doses le vaccin
father et très efficace contre ce
variant le astrazeneca fait également du
bon travail
par contre la protection est faible
après une seule dose de massage faits et
vole trop on sait également que ce
variant est plus contagieux que les
autres et qu'il devrait continuer à
gagner du terrain en europe et ailleurs
présentement je pense que le variant
britannique est prédominant ils ont
remplacé le variant de one ou la source
originale de guan et je pense que ces
variants l'avons tous avoir des cycles
qui vont se faire remplacer un après
l'eau le royaume uni a récemment réduit
de quatre semaines le délai entre
l'administration des deux doses de
vaccin pour les personnes de 50 un put
une mesure qui pourrait permettre un
meilleur contrôle du variant indien
des données récentes indiquent également
que la protection offerte par une seule
dose de father who d'astrazeneca est un
peu moins efficace que prévu pour
réduire les symptômes les
hospitalisations et les décès et ce peu
importe la souche de covin au québec les
cas tu veux rien et ils sont encore
rares mais réduit les délais entre deux
doses pourraient quand même être
avantageux selon ce spécialiste
surprendre époque le 16 semaines qu'on
avait auparavant va devenir un 12
semaines puis je pense que l'on peut
donner à voir des annonces à ce sujet
lors
bientôt tu serais très bien mais
peut-être aussi faut réfléchir à savoir
si on devrait même pas aller plus vite
le variant est bien est maintenant
présent dans une cinquantaine de pays
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal